bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette édition
du journal une nouvelle semaine débute
et au sommaire ce soir des
rassemblements organisés un peu partout
ce week-end je suis charlie scandé de
versailles à rambouillet en passant par
saint quentin en yvelines le détail dans
quelques instants une artiste de
l'agglomération a également rendu
hommage à sa façon le premier ministre
maintient le plan vigipirate heures
renforcée à son maximum comment doivent
s'organiser les communes nous en
parlerons dans quelques instants avec le
directeur général des services de la
ville de guyancourt et puis en sport du
handball à montigny-le-bretonneux
recevait villemomble un choc entre les
deux formations qui caracole aux
premières places du championnat national
2 montini s'impose avec la manière d'un
petit point
dimanche 15 heures départ des
manifestants place de la république à
paris parmi les personnalités politiques
que l'on a pu apercevoir hier il y avait
un gérard larcher le président du sénat
le numéro deux de l'état sénateurs donc
des yvelines et c'est dans sa commune de
rambouillet qu'à la même heure 1 défilés
étaient également organisés du parvis de
la gare à la mairie environ dix mille
personnes y ont participé c'est le plus
important défilé du département
une fois de plus tous unis derrière une
seule volonté rendre hommage aux
victimes et dire non à la barbarie avec
pour unité le drapeau bleu blanc rouge
et je suis charlie un rassemblement
d'élus et de citoyens je pense que le
message est bien sûr et très très très
important c'est l'avenir de notre pays
quelque part qui se joue depuis quelques
heures et dire écoutez c'est aussi le
représentant de la république de porter
ces messages ce que nous avons fait
d'une façon très très humble aujourd'hui
à rambouillet mais avec aussi beaucoup
de force oui c'est de l'émotion mais de
l'eau mais l'émotion compétentes et avec
toute la force qui nous unis ont lavé
aujourd'hui haranguer nous entre en
résistance pour que nos libertés soient
sauvés je suis abdelkader j'en suis fier
mais ma république est fière aussi
d'avoir abdelkader à la tête d'une
circonscription telle que celle de
rambouillet chargé d'histoire changer de
toute l'histoire de la france c'est pas
une réaction en particulier à charlie
hebdo ça aurait pu être le canard ça
aurait pu être n'importe quel autre
journal c'est c'est la même chose on tue
la liberté d'expression charlie hebdo
était bien sûr réputé pour ses
caricatures les traits de crayon célèbre
de cabu charb et tant d'autres
leur mort a éveillé chez certains robots
lutins des envies de prendre le crayon
j'ai eu envie de cépages avait dit j'ai
un copain dans le photo club bouchut qui
avait fait 1 avait fait un croquis pjj
je subis une voile fait de papier que
j'ai pu j'ai laissé faire le crayon qui
tous peuvent pas s'y fier un moyen de
rendre hommage c'est un bien grand mot
mais j'ai eu envie de faire je les fais
dans cette marche républicaine se
côtoyaient toutes les générations et
même les citoyens de demain une occasion
pour certains parents de partager leurs
valeurs la semaine a été très difficile
avant tout pour nous et aussi pour eux
c'était un choc
pour toute la famille on leur a transmis
voilà qu'est ce qu'on a ressenti nous et
et on a été touché droit au coeur voilà
on a pu leur transmettre ce que ce en
quoi on croit et ce en quoi on pense dix
mille personnes ont défilé à rambouillet
s'ajoutant ainsi aux près de 4 millions
de français qui se sont rassemblés un
peu partout dans le pays faisant de
cette journée un événement historique
et puis la veille samedi dans la matinée
c'est à montigny le bretonneux que les
habitants se sont également retrouvés à
l'appel de l'année sipa lité une marche
qui a rassemblé 3000 personnes et qui
s'était tiré de l'avenue nicolas bour
jusqu'à l'hôtel de ville marche donc à
laquelle ont participé les citoyens un
cortège mené vous l'avez vu par le maire
de la commune et président de
l'agglomération michel logis entouré
donc d'élus de la ville dans le cortège
des représentants également des
différents cultes et de nombreux enfants
une marche pour affirmer distillent leur
solidarité farouche et déterminé face
aux attentats une délégation d'élus et
ni mon teint s'est d'ailleurs rendu
dimanche au défilé parisien et puis la
banderole vous l'avez vu nous sommes
charlie a été symboliquement posée sur
le fronton de la mairie et au pied des
arbres des bougies et des crayons en
papier et puis également samedi un autre
rassemblement à la même heure cette fois
magny les hameaux auquel se sont
associés environ 200 habitants à manier
aussi ils étaient tous charlie mélanie
parfait et patrick jacquemin
10h45 à magny les hameaux habitants et
élus se rassemblent pour un dernier
hommage sans un bruit la foule se rend
devant la mairie sous les mots de
liberté égalité fraternité
une gerbe de fleurs et déposer un acte
fort et symbolique
je vous appelle au rassemblement
au rassemblement pour notre république
pour la pérennité de nos libertés et
surtout de ne pas répondre aux élans de
stigmatisation qui pourraient se faire
jour
actuellement une minute de silence puis
la marseillaise retentit
l'émotion est forte pour les centaines
de personnes venues montrer leur soutien
ça donne un sentiment de comment vous
dire d'union en fait de d'union entre
tous entre tout le monde toutes les
personnes qui ont été touchées par ces
événements j'ai touché je pense que
c'est il ya des événements qui sont
intolérables et je pense que face à ça
on n'a pas le choix que de se mobiliser
donc il faut absolument absolument faire
face faire face et être tous ensemble
sur des événements comme ça pour montrer
que quoi qu'il arrive enfin les français
sont sont des gens de liberté et qu'on
n'est pas prêt à aller à céder à ses
libertés pour l'occasion les différents
représentants politiques de magny les
hameaux ont tenu à apparaître uni et
diffuser le même message
aujourd'hui il faut absolument appeler
au rassemblement a appelé justement à ne
pas stigmatiser à ne pas diviser la
république elle est une elle est
indivisible et elle est unie dans
l'ensemble de sa diversité et c'est ça
qui fait la france et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui voilà ce rassemblement
était essentielle au delà des
différences et elles sont nombreuses il
y à quelque chose qui est plus fort et
plus important qu'est la république il
faut que au delà de cette émotion que
l'on a aujourd'hui que ça retombe pas et
que demain on n'est pas le risque de
stigmatisation d'un certain nombre de
populations des gens qui ont peur je
pense à la communauté musulmane qui à
part je pensais la communauté juive qui
a été à nouveau attaqué les élus ont
également salué le travail des forces de
l'ordre tous sont appelés les citoyens à
venir manifester dimanche à paris lors
du grand rassemblement républicain
et puis enfin à versailles c'est
dimanche aux alentours de 18 heures
qu'un appel au rassemblement a aussi été
lancée place du marché notre dame à
l'appel de la municipalité 7000
personnes vont participer sont venus
déposer une bougie sur une estrade mise
en place pour l'occasion
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
et un message délivré par le maire de la
commune un appel à défendre la liberté
d'expression je brosse d'écouté françois
de mazières oui à la liberté
d'expression
oui à la liberté conscience lui à la
liberté de croire ou de ne pas croire
mais avant tout le respect de la
personne humaine et puis une émotion
également particulière pour certains
versailles et puisque cabu a été élève
au lycée hoche de versailles dans les
années 50 et c'est d'ailleurs pendant
ces années lycéennes que jean cabu de
son vrai nom avait créé le personnage du
grand duduche élèves maladroit mais
sympathique couverture que l'on
reconnaît bien et puis dans ce contexte
assez lourd cette affaire qui ne peut
pas passer inaperçu le 24 décembre
dernier aux mureaux un véhicule de
police a été percuté par une voiture qui
roulait à vive allure dans cette voiture
les policiers ont retrouvé un fusil de
type kalachnikov ainsi que de chargeurs
l'individu d'une trentaine dernier
d'année appartient à la communauté des
gens du voyage est un multirécidiviste
et déféré le 26 décembre il a été
condamné à quatre mois de prison ferme
remich et depuis en liberté dans un
communiqué publié aujourd'hui le
syndicat alliance des yvelines déplore
cette décision judiciaire et demande
l'application stricte de la loi on va
maintenant s'intéresser au plan
vigipirate renforcé alerte attentats
daniel seguin qualif bonsoir directeur
général des services de la mairie de
guyancourt et c'est dans ce contexte que
le premier ministre manuel valls a
rappelé ce matin que le plan vigipirate
déclenché le 7 janvier au niveau alerte
le plus haut et maintenaient encore et
toujours maintenu il faut savoir que ce
l'origine de ce plan vigipirate remonte
à
1978 en 1995 le plan gouvernemental
pirates a été instauré il y avait quatre
niveaux d' alerte jusqu'en 2014 et puis
le code d'alerté a été jadis simplifiée
il ya un niveau de vigilance maintenant
qui peut être renforcer temporairement
et puis un niveau d alerte as tu un
attentat pour faire face à une menace
imminente nous sommes dans cette alerte
attentat alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement
ça veut dire la préfecture vous a appelé
tout de suite après les attentats sion
venir charlie hebdo on mérite lui en
cours en visant voilà c'est servette
attentats il faut faire vite et bien non
c'est à dire que la la préfecture ils
nous avaient alertés bien bien en amont
puisque d'aider les événements de
joué-lès-tours et d'autres événements la
préfecture monsieur le préfet nous avait
adressé un courrier nous indiquons que
nous étions passés en alerte attentats
et l'alertent attentats ça sous-entend
de mesures exceptionnelles dans un temps
limité
il est vrai que des ensuite les
événements malheureux à charlie hebdo le
maire françois de ligne et a souhaité
lui
réunir une cellule de crise et prendre
des mesures qui s'imposaient dans les
plus brefs délais
entendant le cellule de crise on se
demande toujours qu'il ya dans cette
cellule de crise c'est une cellule de
crise donc alors en présence tous
présidée par monsieur le maire en
présence du premier adjoint du maire
adjoint chargé de la sécurité du
directeur de cabinet du maire et de
moi-même directeur général des services
dans cette cellule de crise on réfléchit
à aqua gym en place les fameuses 300
mesures que compte le nom 3 300 mesures
simples plus compliqué elle s'adresse
pas obligatoirement aux communes mais
c'est ça c'est surtout à prendre des
mesures de bon sens et protéger les
établissements scolaires par la mise en
place de barrières c'est protéger les
accès ses contrôles et ses demandes au
personnel communal surveiller c'est
aussi protéger
les policiers municipaux puisque et on
l'a vu avec les événements qui ont suivi
ils ont été également visées et donc on
nous avons demandé aux policiers
municipaux de porter le gilet pare
balles voilà c'est tout un ensemble de
mesures notamment dans le cadre d'un
rassemblement du public on va revenir
sur certains points au niveau des
établissements scolaires qu'est ce qui
se passait les barrières qui sont
installés exactement donc nous avons
souhaité nous avons très vite recenser
le nombre de barrières que nous pouvions
mettre à disposition d'établissements
scolaires de façon à assurer un
périmètre de sécurité et les services
techniques ont dès le mercredi après
midi positionné sur l'ensemble des
équipements scolaires mais également
lycées collèges universités puisque nous
avons dû verser à guyancourt positionner
ses scénarios de façon à protéger les
accès c'est 300 barrière je crois à peu
près
à mi temps quand même sa demande nous a
demandé 24 heures 24 heures vous avez
dit le rôle de la police municipale
c'est de tourner dans la ville s'est
tourné dans la ville il avoir une
attention particulière sur certains
points seulement c'est aussi la présence
à l'hôtel de ville puisque puisque des
des lieux des lieux marquants des bio ou
publics constitutionnels étaient pouvait
faire l'objet d'un attentat c'est la
présence aussi les parts des rondes dans
la ville et puis c'est regarder un peu
ce qui se passe
sont des lieux vraiment symbolique on a
vu que les policiers municipaux étaient
à l'intérieur de la mairie et non à
l'extérieur c'est aussi une volonté ou
cae hasard non c'est pas il ne s'est pas
du tout le hasard c'est une volonté une
décision de façon à aussi les protéger
monsieur le préfet bien nous a bien
indiqué qu'il fallait éviter tous
position toute position statique des
forces de police et donc nous avons
préféré
disposer à l'intérieur de l'hôtel de
ville et à surveiller les entrées
sorties jeux revient aussi sur les
écoles parce que dans le cadre de ce
plan vigipirate alerte attentats toutes
les sorties scolaires sont interdites
c'est un peu plus compliqué que cela
c'est-à-dire que toutes les sorties
inhabituelles sont interdites par contre
ils encourent les enfants continuent à
aller au gymnase pratiqué à ce que les
récents il ya l'étape 1 l'étang
activités
qui sont dans les bâtiments communaux
ont toujours lieu par contre c'est
toutes les sorties je dirais
exceptionnels notamment en ile-de-france
qui sont interdites c'est assez d
éléments qui sont en classe verte où je
sais pas si on dit classes vertes ou
place aux découvertes ont effectivement
nous avons en ce moment une classe de
cm2 qui était en classe de découverte
dans le jura qui doit revenir le le 17
janvier et donc nous sommes en relation
permanente avec la secteur de
l'éducation nationale et donc ils
doivent revenir comme cela était prévu
par le biais de du train et donc nous
toutes les rues de toutes ces conditions
seront réunies pour que ça se passe dans
les meilleures conditions il ya un lieu
de culte musulman à guyancourt est ce
qu'ils ont fait l'objet d'une protection
particulière puisqu'on sait qu'il ya des
actes actuellement anti musulmans qui se
déroulent sur des territoires pas en
paroles de français actuellement nous
avons effectivement des passages
réguliers et de la police municipale et
de la police nationale parce que je
tiens à souligner la collaboration
permanente avec le commissariat de
police et notamment trois dames le
commissaire donc à une collaboration
avec le comme celui en cours ça semble
logique avec la préfecture aussi vous
êtes en rien en échange régulièrement
nous a vons idées ou des circulaires ou
des recommandations de la préfecture et
est ce qu'il ya un lien aussi avec les
autres communes de l'agglomération avec
la castille où chacun fait fait protège
sa commune c'est un non il n'est pas là
pour parler c'est la commune désormais
il n'y a pas de cohérence collaboration
parce qu'il faut quand même rappeler que
le maire françoise 1e c'est que le faire
pour l'ensemble des maires de france en
matière de sécurité est un agent de
l'état et donc relève directement du
préfet donc le maire danser dans ses
prérogatives est en contact direct avec
le préfet sur son territoire donc
effectivement aujourd'hui il ya pas
d'intercommunalité de la sécurité
d'accor non ça serait bien il ya des
territoires où cela existe maintenant
tout en tout cas pour moi ça quand on
dit et quand on est directeur général
des services alain quelle est la plus
grande inquiétude dans ces moments là
l'attitude il faut il faut éviter dans
la voir il faut surtout protège et
rassure et voilà c'est ce que j'essaye
de faire chaque jour une fois qu'ils
aient un courrier d'ailleurs qui va
distribuer au haillan courtois pour leur
action
monsieur le maire a souhaité informer
l'ensemble des concitoyens courtois des
décisions prises et des mesures et
comment légumes quand on réalise qu'ils
vous ont appelé en disant
qu'ils sont allés faire pour nous sont
sereins on les a rencontrés bien
évidemment lors de la minute de silence
et à diverses occasions ils sont sereins
ils savent que nous prendrons toutes les
mesures pour assurer le maximum de
sécurité pour l'instant ça se passe très
bien nos ventes dans le calme on sait
que ce plan vigipirate attentats ni
durée de vie temporaire mais pour
l'instant il est maintenu à ce que ces
jours par jour qui doit évoluer il
évolue il va évoluer en fonction des de
l'actualité bien évidemment
nous on sait qu'il a encore il a encore
il sera encore en état durant quelques
jours nous attendons de la part de
l'état de plus amples informations merci
daniel fialin nous apporter cet
éclairage sur le plan vigipirate donc
installé sur toutes les communes de
france est notamment sur celle
évidemment de guyancourt merci beaucoup
avant de poursuivre ce journal cette
information concernant un incendie
survenu dimanche matin avant 5h au
cinquième foyer de cinquième étage du
foyer adef de coignières le feu a
entraîné l'évacuation de 92 personnes
une dizaine d'entre elles a été relogés
dans un hôtel de coignières et une
enquête a été ouverte pour déterminer
l'origine de l'incendié
allez on revient sur lui en cour demain
le présent de l'agglomération à michel
auger présentera ses voeux aux
personnalités une cérémonie qui aura
lieu pour la première fois au vélodrome
est l'occasion de faire le point sur les
projets à venir dans les communes
exemple donc à guyancourt ce cas la
ville vous réserve pour 2015 le point
avec anthony rech
pour ses premiers voeux de son second
mandat le maire socialiste de guyancourt
françois de ligne et a rappelé son
attachement au vivre ensemble et aux
échanges intergénérationnels il a
également insisté sur la nécessité
d'approfondir l'application de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires afin de
refondre l'école dans son ensemble côté
projets après l'ouverture du nouveau
groupe scolaire lurçat triolet 2015 sera
synonyme de la mise en route le 12
janvier du deuxième pôle multi-accueil
poulbot pour la petite enfance en
matière de santé l'année 2015 verra le
début de la construction d'une clinique
de soins de suite qui devrait permettre
de créer une centaine d'emplois autre
projet cochet la création d'une maison
de santé pluridisciplinaire avila roi
l'objectif regrouper les médecins et
autres professionnels spécialisés avec
des consultations sans rendez vous
devez également à magny les hameaux
c'était à lundi soir dernier pas de
grande annonce à l'occasion de ses voeux
mais toutefois des dossiers qui avance
les annonces faites par le maire de
magny les hameaux sont d'abord d'ordre
économique bertrand au lion a rappelé
l'installation de safran qui finalise
son implantation sur une partie de magny
les hameaux et une autre sur château
fort sur le plan des entreprises c'est
encore la société su méga tronic un
fleuron familiale de l'industrie
aéronautique qui s'agrandit actuellement
et dernière annonce cette fois le
concerne le commerce les travaux
d'intermarché et de la galerie marchande
doivent démarrer prochainement des
commerçants qui ont pu bénéficier d'un
accompagnement technique et financier de
la part du parc naturel de la haute
vallée de chevreuse des voeux où il a
été question également d'agriculture
biologique avec le projet d'installation
d'un maraîcher bio dans le quartier du
buisson le dossier de la ligne à haute
tension est toujours d'actualité une
étude a été chiffrée pour la réalisation
des travaux 4 5 millions d'euros sont
nécessaires pour les trouver ce sera
peut-être du côté de l'europe qu'il
faudra aller les chercher dossier à
suivre cette année
et du sport pour continuer un match au
sommet ce samedi soir en handball pour
le compte de la 11ème journée de
national de montigny le bretonneux
troisième recevait le deuxième à
villemomble dans un match qui
ressemblait un duel peut-être décisif
pour la montée en fin de saison lésigny
montait n'ont pas tremblé match serré
mais matches gagnés
en 2015 il faut croire que les entames
de match en mode diesel cela n'existe
plus à montigny face aux deuxièmes
villemomble lésiné monteyne ne se laisse
pas piéger après un quart d'heure de jeu
elle mène de quatre buts 9 à 5 dans une
première période très serré électrique
les deux équipes se répondent coup pour
coup
la pause rien n'est fait montini mène
d'une longueur 13 à 12 on s'est fait
peur quand il avait ex-aequo et on a su
remonter au score donc c'était pas mal
et reprendre nos esprits surtout écouté
les consignes du coach et pierre des
joueuses en place et on a fait le boulot
derrière car villemomble est une des
deux seules équipes à avoir fait chuter
le leader havrais cette saison les
joueuses de seine saint denis le prouve
et s'accroche au score mais les joueuses
de philippe l'étrange ne reproduisent
pas les erreurs commises à lisieux lors
de la 10e journée rigoureuse jusqu'au
bout elle s'impose finalement d'un petit
but 24-23 grâce notamment à 8 banderille
de carole mittelheisser une victoire
précieuse face à un concurrent pour la
montée qui pourrait faire basculer leur
fin de saison très tendu très serré on a
réussi à aller tenue robert on était
devant tout noir et y avoir moyen qu'ont
père noël a cédé par ici votez pas mais
si on est restée sereine et propre pas
trop deux minutes la montée on y pense
un parce que je pense qu on a fait pas
mal d'erreurs notamment sur deux matches
perdus 1 à lisieux et l'autre contre
saint michel chez nous et je pense que
les matches retour va être très
important puisque la face de tout
recommencer maintenant
voilà bravo aux minimes on tenait dans
quelques instants ne manquez pas le 7-8
sports présenté par anthony rech voilà
ce que vous pouvez dire en ce lundi 12
janvier va maintenant se quitter en
musique et charlie gones compositrice et
chanteuse saint-quentinoise a souhaité à
sa manière rendre hommage aux victimes
de la fusillade contre charlie hebdo à
travers la reprise d'un de ses titres
réécrit pour la circonstance en voici un
extrait bonne soirée
peut-on juste d'imaginer
ce qui c'était
jai elle dit
seck janvier dernier
peut être juste imagine
c'est qu'est leurs yeux
cette attente
quand justin à jour
deux temps juste imaginer
non surement tous les jours
si ce serait rater
tous horizons
si le prêt ne sont m
allez on y croit peu denses seulement
imaginer
seulement imagine